في سوق العمل هناك تخصصات لا تتطلب شهاده
تعليميه لكن الخبره فيها لها اليد العليا
هذا ما تقول دراسه امريكيه جديده وجدت ان
تخصصات مثل التكنولوجيا والهندسه
والرياضيات لا تحتاج سنوات من الدراسه بل
تتطلب خبره عمليه اكثر من الخبره النظريه
البحث الجديد يعتبر الشهاده شيء ثانوي
ويعتمد على ان نحو
ثلثه احدى الولايات الامريكيه جاءت
اعتمادا على الخبرات العلميه القائمون على
البحث لم ينفو اهميه الشهادات لكنهم
ابرزوا ان اغلب الطلاب يحصلون عليها من
اجل المظهر الاجتماعي امولينا في النظر
باعوام الدراسه والسعي لتخفيضها
موقع المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي ينصح
المؤسسات بضروره التركيز على احتضان
المواهب بدلا من النظر الى الشهادات
الجامعيه فقط ورشح ثلاث خطوات ربما تساعد
على تحقيق ذلك اولا تدريب وتطوير الموظفين
الحاليين في الشركه ما يوفر الوقت والمال
المطلوبين عند التوظيف الخارجي وعند فتح
باب التوظيف يفضل البحث عن الاشخاص
القابلين للتعلم وهي اهم مهاره بالنظر
للمتغيرات المتلاحقه والمهارات الجديده
التي ستكون مطلوبه في المستقبل ثالثا
التوظيف على اساس الاداء المتوقع بدلا من
التوظيف على اساس الخبرات السابقه وهو نهج
يساعد على الوصول الى اصحاب الافكار
الابداعيه وتطوير المواهب اخيرا اجراء
محادثات مهنيه منتظمه مع الموظفين فهذا
يساعد في ترسيخ ثقافه التعلم وزي اده
انتاجيه الموظفين وشعورهم بالانتماء على
كل حال سالنا الناس في السعوديه هل انت مع
الشهاده الجامعيه ام الخبره العمليه
لتحقيق النجاح لنتابع
[موسيقى]
انا مش مع الشهاده ولا مع الخبره انا مع
اي مهاره ممكن الواحد يكسب منها رزق حلال
انا معاه الخبره العمليه ماني مع الشهاده
الجمعيه ابدا
يعني الا في حاله واحده انك تكون الجمعيه
يعني مهندس
في افضل معلم الممارسه
الشهاده يعني بس الخبره العمليه افضل مع
الشهاده الجامعيه اكيد
اكيد الواحد يدرس ويتعلم ويكون الخبره مع
الشهاده الجامعيه طبعا انا مع المهارات
اكثر من خبره ومن الشهاده اوكي الخبره
حلوه لكن المهارات انا والله مع الاثنين
يعني الخبره والشهاده يعني اذا كانوا مع
بعض اتوقع يعني
حيكون يعني حاجه كويسه يعني طبعا العمليه
يعني طبعا انا مع خبرتي هي الخبره العمليه
هي اللي ساعدتني اني اتاهل لوظيفتي لا
بصراحه الخبره الخبره هي اللي تثبت النجاح
وهذا عن تجربه طبعا
[موسيقى]
معنا الان مشاهدينا من جد المستشار في
التطوير الشخصيه طراد سنبل اهلا بك يا
طراد معنا مره اخرى في صباح العربيه
نورتنا وطولت علينا
انعكاس دوركم العاب الوراويه
الله يخليك طيب خلينا نحط الامور في
نصابها وبسياقها الصحيحه هون الحديث وهذه
دراسه تتحدث عن اختصاصات معينه لا تحتاج
الى الشهاده الخبره فيها تكون اكثر يعني
مطلوبه اكثر والها قيمه اكبر لانه من
المستحيل انك تكون مثلا عندك ثقه في طبيب
مدرسه طب
ولكن عنده خبره
جميل خلينا نستثني الطب لانه الطب يحتاج
حتى الممارسات تكون باشراف اطباء تحتاج
تكون دارس فاهم ايش الاشياء استعملها
فالطب الاستثناء يعني لازم الواحد يدخل
لكن زي ما اتفضلوا في التقرير قالوا باقي
تخصصات اول كنا نقول الطب والهندسه الان
حتى الهندسه في كورسات مختصه ممكن الواحد
حتى ياخذها اونلاين خليني اعطيك هل اذا
انت صاحبه عمل وعندك انسان دارس له في
شهاده جامعيه وجايب مرتبه الشرف الاولى
وما عنده اي خبره عمليه وجاي بشهاده هو
دارس مثلا انتاج ولا دارس اخراج وعندك شخص
ممارس وعنده افلام ولا عنده اعلانات ولا
عنده مواد منتجه وبيجيب لك اياها ويجيب لك
راي العملاء وبجيب لك ردات فعلهم وبجيب لك
انعكاس هذا الامر ماديا على الشركه اللي
كان يشتغل فيها هتوظف يمين فهذا الطبيعي
للان سائر انتم شفتوا
الموظفين بدون اعتمادات على الشهادات لانه
دون موقع مرسوم رئاسي عدم اعتماده
الاكاديميه حتى في الوظائف الحكوميه
يقول الجامعه هذي الناس تروح تتمشى فيها
تخصصات يعني الها دخل في التكنولوجيا مش
تخصصات التقليديه اللي احنا يعني متعودين
عليها
اعطيني مثال الان خليني اقول لك مثلا عادل
على سبيل المثال ابو عيسى الناس شافوه في
في مشاغباته مع الفنانين في الكويت وفي
الاذاعه وفي الاعلام العربيه يعني الناس
يبغوا يشوفوك على ارض الواقع وفي استثناء
لكن انا في النهايه ابغى على ارض الواقع
يعني تخيلي الان اي شخص عنده اي موهبه
سويها على السوشيال ميديا وري الناس ايش
بتعمل انا اعرف اعلاميين لا درسوا اعلام
ولا سووا شيء طلعوا اعطوا مواهبهم وسوي
لقاءاتهم على السوشيال ميديا على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الان هذا السلاح اللي
تعرف الناس فيه طيب اطراد خليني اولا انا
ترى مع الشهاده لسبب واحد انه احنا درسنا
هالاربع سنين وتعبنا وغيرنا ما يدرس لا
والله ما اقبلها لكن خليني اقول بانه
اليوم بالفعل ربما الخبره والممارسه تكون
هي
العلامه الفارقه بين الشخصين يقدمون نفس
المنتج لكن اليوم بعض الجهات الاكاديميه
تطلب بل تفرض الممارسه اثناء الدراسه حتى
يخرج هذا التلميذ او الطالب معه الخبره
النظريه وكذلك العلميه يعني
مسكت العصب للنص كما يقال
جميل جدا هذا من اجمل الامثله واللي طالب
فيها الان نقول للناس لا تنتظر الانترنت
ولا سنه الامتياز ولا اخر السنه عشان تسوي
تجربه شركه في جامعات امريكيه بتعمل كل
الصيف او ترمن من كل سنه تخلي الطلاب
يروحوا يتعلموا مباشره في العربيه عندنا
عندنا طلبه اعلام وطلبه صحافه ياتون
ليمارسوها في فتره الصيف
هذا هو المثال الافضل للموضوع لانه الفكره
الان زي ما تفضلت خليني اعطيك مثال اخر
عادل عشان الفكره انه المناهج الدراسيه
عشان تعتمد خصوصا في الجامعات العربيه انت
تقدم المنهج لوزاره التعليم وزاره التعليم
تكون لجنه تقيم المنهج على اساسه وبعدين
اعتمدت المنهج ولا لا هذا ياخذ منه تقريبا
سنه انت خلف السوق بسنه تخيل لما اجي اقول
لك الان المنه تتعلمه وعندي امثله عبد
الرحمن الشريف نريد اعلام في في جامعه في
الرياض فهذا الانسان راح اتدرب في قناه في
قناه تلفزيونيه صار يصحح للدكتور
المعلومات الدكتور يقول له الكاميرات
دكتور طورت الان هذا الانسان الشرف واشتغل
انا بس
طبعا اشواق خلص دمرتني وقالت لي ولا كلمه
المره الجايه نتحدث
لنا على الثانيه ما يصير
راح نرجع راح نكمل هذا الحديث لانه بالفعل
يعني نقطه شائكه ولسه في الكثير اللي ما
نناقشه
بشكرك جزيلا شكر
في التطوير لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات